I know this is pretty complicated and that's why this entire lesson is pretty
much on confidence intervals. Let's just analyze a good old normal distribution.
So here we have 95%, well if 95% is in the middle that means 2.5% is here and
2.5% is here. So what's the Z score here? If you look at the Z table, and look
for 0.025, or 2.5%, you see that it's at negative 1.96. So Z is negative 1.96
here and positive 1.96 here. So 0.13 can either be 1.96 standard deviations
above the mean, like it is here if this were the population distribution. Z 0.13
is 1.96 standard deviations above mu sub i. Or 0.13 can be 1.96 standard
deviations below the true population mean. So if this sample mean is 1.96
standard deviations below the true population mean, then this true population
mean would be the sample mean plus 1.96 standard deviations away. And you found
that 1 standard deviation is 0.024. However, if the sample mean is actually
greater than the true population mean, then the true population mean is 0.13
minus 1.96 standard deviations. And then if we calculate what these values are
we get .083, approximately, and .177. So then our interval estimate for the 95%
confidence interval has a lower bound of 0.083. And an upper bound of 0.177. Now
really quick, always remember what these numbers mean. Most numbers have units
of some sort. This is the ratio of minutes watched of all the lessons to total
minutes available. So we're predicting that, if I incorporated this musical
lesson then the entire population of 8,702 students will watch between 83
thousandths and 177 thousandths of all content available. So if we set it up
like this and we want to know how many minutes students will watch out of every
60 minutes available, 60 times 0.083 is about 5 minutes. And then on the upper
bound, they could watch up to 0.177 minutes for every minute available. And out
of 60 minutes, that's about 10.62. Since we found that the engagement ratio
right now Is 0.077. That's about 4.62 minutes watched out every hour of content
available. Then according to our calculations, we're pretty sure that this
musical lesson will increase the amount video watched to at least 5 minutes and
possibly up to 10.62 minutes for every hour of content available. So if all of
this actually happened, then we could say that my song increased the engagement.